>>Female Presenter: We are joined today by
chefs Anita Lo and April Bloomfield.
Anita Lo is the chef and owner of Annisa,
which opened in 2000, right nearby in Greenwich
Village.
She appeared on "Top Chef Masters," finishing
in the final four of "24 Chefs."
And Chef Lo released her first cookbook, "Cooking
Without Borders," in October of 2011.
And April Bloomfield is the executive chef
and co-owner of the Michelin-starred The Spotted
Pig, The Breslin, and the John Dory restaurants.
She released her first cookbook, "A Girl and
Her Pig" in April of this year.
Please join me in welcoming chefs Anita Lo
and April Bloomfield.
[applause]
Well, thank you so much for being here at
Google.
I was telling some friends about this panel
over the weekend.
And interestingly, a few people asked me,
they're like, "Oh, so you're doing a panel
on women chefs."
I was like, "Well, no.
We're doing a panel with a few chefs who happen
to be women."
And if people are wondering why did we bring
you in together, it was a few reasons.
I mean, there's other reasons to bring you
in beside the fact that you're both amazing
chefs, that you have incredible cookbooks
that have come out that I hope many of you
have been able to buy and enjoy.
You also have restaurants in the neighborhood
right nearby Google's offices, which I hope
to be able to get a table anytime I want.
So, there's always that secret agenda in all
of our charading here at Google.
And also, you happen to be great friends.
So, we thought that would just be a really
great conversation.
But I thought it really raised an interesting
question about gender in the kitchen and the
fact that people would react that way and
say, "Oh, it's a panel of women chefs."
Because if we had two guys up here, they wouldn't
say, "Well, it's a panel of male chefs."
And I was wondering, well I imagine you get
that a lot as two of the women at the forefront
of your industries.
How do you react to that when people say,
"Well, we'd like you on a panel on women chefs."
If I was calling this panel skirt steak, would
that change your approach to coming?
[laughter]
>>April Bloomfield: I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't think about the men and women thing
very much.
I just do my thing and I just, Anita being
here as my friend.
I don't see Anita as a woman.
I do, but sorry.
[laughter]
I didn't mean it like that.
>>Anita Lo: She always has these quips about
me.
>>April Bloomfield: But I just don't think
about it.
So, actually when you said that, I was like,
"Oh.
Ok."
Now I'm thinking about it, but--.
>>Anita Lo: I think I've been forced to think
about it.
We're constantly being asked like, about,
'cause we're such a minority.
And just constantly being asked about it.
And I think it's an interesting question.
It's something, it's something, it's something
to think about.
Yes, you always wanna just be a chef and be
recognized as a chef, as a good chef.
But at the same time, there is that discrepancy.
And it's interesting to think about why.
>>Female Presenter: Well, I would love to
know about how you each got interested in
cooking, if you can just tell us a little
bit about that.
Sort of, your journey.
>>Anita Lo: You can go.
[laughs] I don't know.
I came from a food obsessed family.
We ate a lot of Chinese, which is if you're
Chinese, pretty much you're food obsessed.
We were always talking about the next meal
and traveling just to go eat something.
And yeah.
I just always loved food.
And I was trying to learn how to cook for
myself in college.
And I just became obsessed with it.
And I was studying French at the time in order
to immerse myself in the language.
I went to France.
And I ended up falling in love with that culture.
And ended up going to cooking school there.
>>April Bloomfield: Well, my mother wasn't
a very good cook.
So, I needed to learn to cook I think as a
way to survive.
But my, if your mom's a bad cook, you'll understand.
But I really went to school because I didn't
get into my chosen profession, which I wanted
to do, which was to be a police woman in the
Metropolitan Police Force.
So, I had to do something to fall back on.
And my two sisters at the time were at cooking
school.
So, I just, I was like three weeks away from
leaving school and my mom sat me down and
was like, "What are you gonna do?"
So, I said, "Well, maybe I'll just cook, do
two years, and then maybe reapply for the
police force."
And fortunately, that didn't happen.
Fortunately, I've had a great journey getting
where I am and yeah.
That's how it all started.
>>Female Presenter: So, I'm glad you didn't
become part of a police force.
I think everybody here would agree.
The Spotted Pig was a much better choice.
So, how did you actually find yourself at
The Spotted Pig?
That's a pretty interesting partnership with
Mario Batali and Ken Friedman.
And I think a lot of people may not know that--
>>April Bloomfield: Right.
>>Female Presenter: that the three of you
are in that together.
>>April Bloomfield: Basically, I was working
in a restaurant in England called the River
Cafe--fantastic place.
I really enjoyed working there.
If I hadn't got this opportunity in New York,
I'd probably still be there now.
But yeah.
I was working there.
I'd gone as far as I could.
And I got this call from a guy called Ken
Friedman, who is now my business partner at
The Spotted Pig.
And he invited me over for a weekend.
And I came over, met Mario Batali, ate in
like, ten restaurants in two days, wobbled
back on the plane after a huge meal.
And yeah, I took the jump.
And I'm really happy to be here.
I love New York.
Love the people, food.
>>Female Presenter: Well, you have this incredible
knack, it seems, for opening these off the
beaten path little places that become real
destinations.
Can you tell us a little bit about how that
happened?
Was that Mario Batali and Ken Friedman knowing
the neighborhoods and deciding this was where
we needed the Gastro Pub in the West Village?
>>April Bloomfield: Well, it helped that Ken
lived opposite The Spotted Pig.
So, that worked 'cause he knew that area.
But we've just opened a restaurant two years
ago called The Breslin on 29th and Broadway.
And that was a risk.
So, none of us knew that area very well.
But we got this great opportunity to work
with Ace Hotel and Alex, who is the founder
of the Ace Hotel brand.
And we just took a leap of faith and we felt
like it would work.
And thank God it did.
And opened another restaurant right there,
too.
>>Female Presenter: What about Annisa?
Can you tell us a little bit about how that
came to be?
It's been open now over ten years, twelve
years.
>>Anita Lo: Twelve years.
Well, I had been the chef of a restaurant
called Mirezi on 5th Avenue.
And it was a restaurant that didn't survive.
And I was doing Pan Asian cuisine there.
And I realized that I really wanted to just
do Contemporary American.
I didn't wanna be defined by that.
And, 'cause that's really who I am.
I've been all over.
I grew up in the Midwest.
So, and I'm French trained.
So, I realized that in order to get full creative
freedom, I needed to open my place.
And yeah.
So, I met my partner--my business partner--Jen.
Had been my sous chef a long time ago.
And we got together and found this little
place in the West Village.
Made it happen.
>>Female Presenter: OK.
Well, so Annisa tragically suffered a pretty
major fire a few years ago.
And during that time, you went on "Top Chef
Masters," which is being discussed as, you're
number four, which is pretty amazing.
How did that experience change your life or
your cooking?
>>Anita Lo: Actually, we filmed "Top Chef
Masters" before the fire.
And it actually aired like, two weeks after
the fire.
So, it was kind of doubly tragic 'cause I
thought I would miss that whole wave of publicity
and driving business to the restaurant.
We were closed for nine months.
I thought I had lost the restaurant on three
occasions just because it took forever to
get the insurance money.
And then, the insurance money wasn't enough.
And also, at the time, we had to renegotiate
our lease.
So, yeah.
It was really hard.
I came back.
I don't think it changed my cooking.
I think I'm still cooking the same way.
It made me appreciate my restaurant more.
It made me appreciate my staff.
Every single one of my staff came back to
open that restaurant except for one.
And so, I just was so grateful.
>>Female Presenter: That's incredible.
Do you feel that "Top Chef Masters" and being
on that show has changed anything?
I mean, you said that you couldn't ride the
wave of that publicity in terms of the actual
restaurant.
>>Anita Lo: Oh, my gosh.
Yeah.
I mean, business is, people are still coming
in from it.
It's so interesting because it aired so long
ago.
And I guess it keeps re-airing.
>>April Bloomfield: It's good to get that
second wave.
>>Anita Lo: Yeah.
>>Female Presenter: And April, have you ever
thought about competing on a show like that?
>>April Bloomfield: No.
I'm not a very competitive person.
I just, I like to just do what I do and just
hope that people like it.
And I don't like that competitive energy that
you get.
No.
Not really.
I did "Iron Chef" once and I didn't know whether
I should do it or not, so I asked my staff.
I said, "Look, what shall I do it?"
And they went like, "Yeah.
Do it."
But when I got there on the day, I was like,
super nervous just like now actually.
So, I was a complete wreck and I got to the
kitchen stadium.
And it was pretty daunting.
But then I saw my staff walk in to sit down.
And I was like, "Oh, I can't do this."
I was about to like, run out the door.
Anyway, I managed to focus.
It's funny how when you start cooking, it's
very natural so you feel comfortable and you
get to this place where you're happy.
So, that, as soon as the timer went off, it
was like, it was almost like meditating.
It was like, "OK, this is what I have to do."
So, actually, I won.
I managed to kick Michael Symon's butt on
olives and he's Greek.
[applause]
But I was very happy after it was finished.
>>Female Presenter: And it just ends on a
high note, just to be able to say I won.
>>April Bloomfield: Yeah.
>>Female Presenter: So, talking about the
books.
You both obviously have these incredible books
that just came out somewhat recently.
And I was wondering if you could tell us a
little bit about the inspiration for each
of your books.
[April Bloomfield clears throat]
The pig, obviously, for Chef April was a big
inspiration since you're swathed in that massive
beast.
>>April Bloomfield: Yeah.
I mean, I love everything pork.
But the inspiration was pretty much, there's
a lot of people that go through life that
don't acknowledge where they've learnt stuff
or who they've been influenced by.
And I definitely didn't want to be or become
one of those people.
So, it was like a nod and a thank you to the
people that I've learnt from and pretty much
inspired me and made me the person I am and
the chef I am.
So, that was my vision for the book.
And hopefully that comes across.
I didn't wanna just do a restaurant book.
So, this was kind of personal for me to do.
>>Anita Lo: I've been wanting to write this
book for almost two decades.
I was turned down by agents.
I went to three different agents.
And the reason why I wanted to write this
book was 'cause it was about identity and
it was about what it means to be American
and how do you define an American cuisine.
And I think a lot of people just didn't understand
what that was and didn't understand what Contemporary
American cuisine was.
And I think a lot of people see me as just
Asian 'cause it's just obvious.
But culturally, I'm very diverse.
And I wanted to get that across in this book.
>>Female Presenter: That's great.
So, what are each of your favorite recipes
in your books?
[Anita Lo laughs]
You have to pick one of your children.
>>Anita Lo: You have to stand by all of them
I think.
Yeah.
>>Female Presenter: Is there one that you
would recommend that Googlers try in their
tiny New York kitchens?
We don't have a staff.
>>Anita Lo: I love my Nannie's chicken paprikash.
I grew up with that.
I think it was one of the most delicious things
growing up.
And it is so easy to make.
It's a great, maybe not now, but it's a great
winter dish.
>>April Bloomfield: I think oatmeal, if you
guys like oatmeal.
I'm very passionate about my oatmeal, porridge.
You should definitely try that.
It's super easy actually.
And it takes like 25 minutes to cook.
Just start it on a cold, crisp morning before
you venture off to the office.
It's like perfect.
And actually, you can make it and then reheat
it the next day, too.
>>Female Presenter: Have you cooked with each
others books?
>>April Bloomfield: I haven't.
No.
It's a fallacy that chefs cook at home.
I haven't managed to cook anything yet.
>>Female Presenter: So, Chef Lo, you mentioned
your Nannie's paprikash.
And I was surprised to read about Hungarian
influence in your cuisine, not because I didn't
know about your global influences, but that
was an unexpected influence from my perspective
in reading more about your work.
And I'm curious if there's other unexpected
influences in your work, in your cooking.
>>Anita Lo: I think it's interesting that
I think Japanese cuisine is probably the biggest
influence from Asia that I have in my book.
I know very little about Chinese cuisine.
I'm constantly being asked to represent that.
And I love Chinese cuisine, but it's like
a vast country.
There's so many different cuisines within
it.
And growing up not speaking the language,
my parents didn't teach me Chinese because
it was the '60s and they wanted me to assimilate.
So, a lot of the names of dishes are all Chinese
and they're really just about the ingredient.
So, it's a hard study.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's, I have a lot of influences.
>>Female Presenter: What about you?
>>April Bloomfield: I think my influences
come from mostly Europe, a little bit of Spanish,
a lot of Italian, 'cause I was very influenced
by Rose and Ruth from The River Cafe.
So, I do things that are quite layered and
rustic.
So, lots of pan roasting and slow roasting,
pot roasting, all that kind of stuff.
>>Female Presenter: So, what challenges you
now?
I mean, you have three restaurants now and
you've conquered "Top Chef Masters" and you
both are at the pinnacles of your career.
What really inspires and challenges each of
you in your work now?
>>April Bloomfield: Just to keep pushing,
keep motivating myself, learning new things.
Traveling is a big influence on me.
So, making sure that I get different flavors
and meet different people and eat different
food.
>>Anita Lo: Yeah, managing is always hard.
I mean, I think that's probably the biggest
challenge on a day to day basis.
You always want your staff to be happy and
to be motivated.
I still love to cook.
>>Female Presenter: I guess I have a few fill
in the blanks for you.
Just gonna give you a little phrase and ask
you just to finish my sentence for me.
Ready?
Why are you laughing at me?
I haven't even started yet.
OK.
Ready?
>>April Bloomfield: Right.
>>Female Presenter: Nose to tail eating is--.
>>April Bloomfield: Good for your tummy.
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: Fusion cooking is--.
>>Anita Lo: Fusion cooking is yeah, delicious.
>>Female Presenter: Junk food is--.
>>April Bloomfield: Delicious in moderation.
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: Food bloggers are--.
>>April Bloomfield: Lovely people.
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: My favorite thing about
New York City is--.
>>Anita Lo: Diversity.
>>April Bloomfield: The weather.
I like the weather.
>>Female Presenter: You're coming out of London.
A food trend I hate is--.
>>Anita Lo: There are no food trends that
I hate.
>>April Bloomfield: Yeah.
>>Female Presenter: A food trend I love is--.
>>April Bloomfield: Meatballs.
I like meatballs.
Who doesn't like meatballs?
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: That's kind of like a
trend.
Food trucks are--.
>>Anita Lo: I'm not answering that one.
>>April Bloomfield: Hey, you guys have a food
truck here.
>>Female Presenter: We do.
We do.
>>April Bloomfield: And it goes, it drives.
>>Female Presenter: It just drives to the
office.
No, it doesn't really.
It just stays in one place.
It's more cosmetic, but I think it does function.
>>April Bloomfield: Yeah, I think it does,
yeah.
>>Female Presenter: But we don't take it on
the streets.
It pretty much stays here.
>>April Bloomfield: Yeah.
It looked very clean.
>>Female Presenter: It's very clean.
Reality chef competitions are--.
>>Anita Lo: Stressful.
>>April Bloomfield: I was gonna say the same
thing and I haven't done a competition.
>>Female Presenter: Well, you did do one.
Iron Chef.
OK.
So I have a few other rapid fires and we'll
open it up to the audience for questions.
So, what do you eat when no one is looking?
>>April Bloomfield: Chocolate.
>>Anita Lo: An entire bag of Doritos.
[laughter]
Did I say that?
>>Female Presenter: What is your favorite
restaurant that people should know about?
>>April Bloomfield: Maialino in Gramercy Park.
>>Female Presenter: What should they order
there?
>>April Bloomfield: They should have the lumaconi,
the stuffed lumaconi.
He does it with broccoli rabe and sausage.
And it's just the most divine thing.
And they're like this big and you can pop
the whole one in your mouth.
It's delicious.
>>Female Presenter: Nice.
What do you eat when you're in the walk-in?
>>April Bloomfield: Fruit.
>>Anita Lo: Yeah.
Raw scallops.
>>Female Presenter: Just pop them in like
candy?
>>April Bloomfield: To each his own.
>>Female Presenter: If I came to your house
for dinner--I'm not angling for an invitation.
I'm free Thursday in case you're wondering.
What would you make?
>>April Bloomfield: Pasta.
Yeah.
With a bit of pig face and a little bit of
gravy.
>>Female Presenter: Pasta and pig face.
>>Anita Lo: I don't know.
Roast chicken.
>>Female Presenter: What do you cook to impress
your mom?
>>April Bloomfield: Anything will impress
my mom.
[laughter]
Sorry, Mom.
I'm just kidding.
I'm kidding.
>>Female Presenter: What's in your fridge
right now?
>>Anita Lo: Lots of condiments.
Lots and lots of condiments.
Beer, sake, and--.
>>April Bloomfield: Lots of condiments.
>>Anita Lo: The bottle of wine you brought
over last night.
>>Female Presenter: I sense a theme.
Well, I would love to open it up to questions
from the audience.
And we have two mics set up and we are recording
for YouTube, so if you could go to one of
the mics that would be great.
[pause]
>>Male #1: Hi.
So, I just wanted to say I do love The Spotted
Pig and if there's a special way to get reservations,
I'd love it.
So I noticed that both of your cookbooks,
you each had co-authors.
I'm curious if you could comment on like how
that plays in and where the roles divide and
what it's like writing with someone.
Are they professional chefs?
Are you getting them more for the writing?
That sort of thing.
>>Anita Lo: I tried to write my own book for
two decades and then I realized I didn't have
time.
It took me two decades.
But I wrote maybe a quarter to a third of
it and then I sat down with my author for,
once a week and tap out recipes and etc.,
and came up with headnotes for that, for each
recipe that way.
It was a lovely experience.
Charlotte Druckman is an incredible writer.
She is incredibly smart and is very knowledgeable
about food.
>>April Bloomfield: I am the same as Anita.
I don't think I would have never attempted
to write a cookbook without J.J.
He was a great partner to have.
He loved to eat, which was really a great
thing.
He could eat all my recipe testing.
But he's a great writer.
And he really captured my voice.
We worked well.
It was pretty much like a marriage.
We spent a lot of time together and enjoyed
it so much, we're gonna do another book, which
is great.
So, we're in that process now.
And it's just, yeah.
We feel really good together and we're like
good buddies.
>>Female Presenter: What's the theme of the
next book?
>>April Bloomfield: Can anybody guess?
Vegetables.
>>Female Presenter: Nice.
>>Anita Lo: That's awesome.
I can't wait for this.
>>Female Presenter: You'll be draped in carrots
and beets.
>>April Bloomfield: Yes.
Yeah.
We were thinking of having like, a big beet
root or something.
>>Female #1: Hi.
Thank you both for coming.
So, April, I'm engaged to a man from Yorkshire.
>>April Bloomfield: Oh, you did?
>>Female #1: I did do it.
>>April Bloomfield: Lovely.
>>Female #1: And thank you very much for offering
a full English breakfast at The Breslin.
We frequent that very often.
So, the times when Russell is really missing
home and missing England, what can I make
from the book that might help that?
>>April Bloomfield: That's a good question.
What do I have in there that's--?
Let's see.
>>Female #1: I flipped through it.
I saw a few little English things in there.
>>April Bloomfield: Can you remind--.
Devils.
Devils on Horseback.
Now I've forgotten what's in my book.
But Devils on Horseback, they're very classic
English.
It's basically a re-hydrated prune that we
rehydrate in English breakfast tea.
Can't get more English than that.
And then, it's stuffed with a pickled pear
and then it's wrapped in bacon.
And then, you just toast it under the broiler
until it gets all crispy.
And caramel iced.
The porridge, very English, too.
What else?
The meat pie, yeah.
The beef and Stilton pie, actually, is a very
classic English dish.
Delicious, very easy to make.
>>Female #1: I'll get on it.
Thank you so much.
And then, real quick, I need--.
I don't know if you know, but Taco Bell came
out with this Dorito thing.
[laughter]
I don't know.
I haven't tried it yet.
It's like your number one thing.
So, I need to tell you about it.
>>Anita Lo: I was intrigued.
I saw that.
I saw the commercial and I was totally thinking.
>>Female Presenter: It sounds amazing.
I'm not gonna lie.
>>Anita Lo: Yeah.
>>Female Presenter: It's tempting.
>>Female #2: Thanks again for being here.
It's really inspirational to have you here
and to listen to all of your stories.
I was wondering, other than the cookbook for
you April, is there anything else on the horizon
for either of you that you're able to share
with us today?
[pause]
>>April Bloomfield: I think there's a few
projects in the work but nothing that I can
divulge, unfortunately.
>>Female Presenter: We won't tell anyone.
>>April Bloomfield: Yeah, I know.
But yeah.
Hopefully, they'll pan out and be exciting.
I'm very excited about the projects.
>>Female Presenter: And you'll come back and
tell us all about them?
>>April Bloomfield: Oh, yes.
>>Female Presenter: And then we can put it
out there.
Anita, do you have anything else coming up
that's on the horizon that you could share?
>>Anita Lo: Not at the moment.
I'm focusing on this, I just bought out my
partner in the past two years and I'm focusing
on Annisa.
>>Female #2: Thank you.
>>Male #2: Again, thank you for being here.
Chef Lo, I know when you were on "Top Chef
Masters" you did that for charity.
And I know that you've also done some, you've
been at various charitable events with your
cooking, like The Garden Party, which is tonight.
Can you talk a little bit about philanthropy
and what motivates you?
>>Anita Lo: I think food is always about sharing.
And it's just a shame that it's not being
distributed to everybody.
It's, so a lot of the food charities are very
important to me.
I was the executive chef for the first year,
first two years, of Walk Around Tasting that
we're gonna be doing in September for SHARE,
which is a breast and ovarian cancer support
group.
And it's a wonderful event and I hope you'll
all buy tickets.
It's the third Monday in September, I believe.
And it's at Chelsea Piers and it's all women
chefs cooking to raise money for this.
>>Male #2: Thank you.
>>Female Presenter: Any more questions?
Great.
Well, thank you both so much for being here.
This is really--.
>>April Bloomfield: Thank you.
>>Anita Lo: Thank you so much.
[applause]